in washington for us and aleister two
things just left out to me there
particularly at the tail end of what we
were hearing from president biden well
first
earlier on he made it clear that he
would the americans would replenish the
iron dome system that is
that has been so successful in stopping
practically all of those hamas missiles
getting through
but then on top of that he talked about
dealing directly with the palestinian
authority not hamas
to to continue this fight to stop hamas
from rearming i mean the u.s government
is clearly not stepping away from the
israelis at all if anything getting
slightly closer
no and don't forget hamas is a
designated terrorist organization by
many governments including the us and
the uk but the problem of course
for president biden and the israelis and
anyone else who wants to pursue that
line is that
gaza is controlled by hamas at the
moment whereas uh their political rivals
fatah
are in control of the west bank so uh
therein lies a political problem at the
moment
and i think that hamas will feel that
out of these
last week plus of hostilities they will
have come across to the palestinian
people
as though they are their defenders as
opposed to fatter who have been
rather more quiet but that is the sort
of that is the very complex domestic
politics
uh within uh the palestinian territories
as for the ceasefire itself
due to kicking in about 50 minutes time
i think if my
calculation of time differences between
uh washington london
and uh israel are correct nevertheless
as
we predicted and as as is often the case
although we are very close within
minutes now of a ceasefire there are
still
rockets being fired by all accounts from
both sides as each side tries to have
the final word but the diplomatic
efforts that have been going on
really ever since uh conflict broke out
between the two sides have finally
yielded
some success everybody from uh the
israelis
uh to the white house giving credit to
the egyptians
for again helping uh broker some sort of
truce between the two sides i think it's
the fourth time
that the egyptians have done this in
just over uh 10 years which gives you
some indication as to how cyclical this
violence is
but certainly president biden has
somewhat changed his tune a bit he has
stayed
um you know by his ally
by america's ally israel but from
originally
saying that he respected israel's right
to defend itself
he did change his tone somewhat
yesterday when he said he expected a
swift ceasefire
and he'll be pleased that that has now
come to pass
alastair thank you